hey guys I'm Sharla Lana's odd and I
finally got around to making a room to a
video so this is where it starts just
behind my door here is where I have some
of my pokemon cards so this isn't by any
means all of them but it was sort of
just a way that I wanted to make it ode
to my childhood and yeah that was the
most creative way I think to use those
so then here is my wall of posters down
the bottom here I've got my Hylian shoe
it's pretty cool thing of and these
persons I've obviously got a fire shop
Infinite Crisis 3 Tomb Raider Gears of
War 3 and Halo Reach over there and then
just here is my bed that's where I sleep
and then here is basically my gaming
setup so that Xbox I just used as a
coaster so there's my my projector which
is hooked up to my laptop and my xbox so
the projector screen is actually behind
us in front of my coven so that's how
that works
it's pretty awesome and then here is
probably the highlight of my room so
this is where I hold all the
collectibles that I've gotten so far
I've been collecting for probably two
years now so hopefully this collection
will grow a lot so if the top one here
is my climbing bookshelf even our
talents lumpy Space Princess I've got
venom cable Deadpool iron man
this one here playing a breaking
actually the lights on so that lights up
and that lights up which I really love
we have my injustice statue which I just
got from the game injustice which is
pretty cool the Rope sucks though a
Batarang here and then I got scarecrow
Joker and Batman at the back there this
one here is my anime and manga shelf so
as you can see I've got some characters
from Full Metal Alchemist from Death
Note I've got my yami-yugi which I
really love and I've got a gondola and
obviously unit 1 so I really love this
shelf but I'd really like to grow it a
whole lot and this one Q is just a video
game shelf so here I have Aldo in from
Skyrim I have a custom controller it
doesn't actually work very well but it
looks really cool
Steve for Minecraft a little monster
cheap
and I've got sail from Vanquish and a
Minecraft pickaxe at the back there and
a little tiny Yoshi and this is my
Dragonball shelter I have my Dragon
Balls here which are actually really
cool man pretty well made and then I've
got Kiko up the back II even got his
tail and two Super Saiyan goku's imagine
Vegeta and Vegeta fighting Goku there so
I really like this shelf I would like to
add more and here is my Assassin's Creed
shelf so we're back at the top of the
second cabinet yo so I've got one two
three four five Ezio is in there and
then there's an anti-air there's a
hidden blade gauntlet here which
actually retracts which is pretty cool
an eagle there Connor and Connors
tomahawk up the back there and this is
another miscellaneous game shelf here so
I've got all the starter Pokemon from
the original series I was talking and
then I've got Lara Croft over the side
with a little me sitting next to her
diamonds here from minecraft some Eve
hypo from Bioshock
Batman that's the I'll continue version
a sign up I've had probably since I was
like 6 or 7 a little portal turret wall
from Darksiders Alex Mercer from
prototype and in deaths mask from
Darksiders Big Daddy from Bioshock and
probably the rarest thing I own is up
back there which is John a dark from
perfect up and then a little minecraft
creeper in front about that and this is
a Gears of War show I'd like to put more
on it but nothing really fits so that's
Marcus Fenix the collective statue that
came with years of war 3 this is a snug
pistol it's one of six in Australia it
lights up blue and everything it's
really heavy really cool and then my
name is another Marcus Fenix there and
on the bottom shelf here I have vast
Montenegro from Far Cry 3 because he's
an awesome character a little bit of
dirt there from my croc you got your
volt tech bubble head Pip Boy which is
really cool
behind that I've got a tiny little
Brotherhood of Steel guy there I got
some nuka-cola to go with a little
fallout thing I've got going here
the original Pokemon gym badges Zidane
and squall from Final Fantasy behind
that is a what hog from halo and then
I've got Max Payne there and then Thor's
hammer which is Majoli and this is my
bookshelf here which is in the same
corner as the cabinets so this top shelf
I absolutely love which is all of my art
books that I've gotten so far but I'd
really like to collect all of the studio
ghibli ones because they're awesome and
then I've got a video game comics so
much them are actually really bad the
Assassin's Creed one is good the
prototype one is really awful
and then a couple of game guides that
I've actually never used down on this
shelf is my comic book shop I've got all
my actual comments in there but I mostly
have TPP's here I've got on my mom or my
DC and then all the stuff that wouldn't
fit and then I have my little collectors
here down here is basically just my
books and obviously all of my 64 games
there are some more that don't fit in it
but that's basically is all of my DVDs
and the bottom shelf here is my manga
sir I've got a long piece here Arrietty
manga here full metal alchemist box a
definite box set and my neighbor totoro
and to the right of the bookshelf so
this is all my games there are some more
in the back there because they don't all
fit just above them here we have my
portal gun and here is my customary
brotherhood of steel helmet which I
absolutely love I'll probably be making
a separate video on this entire night
it's also really really light so you can
just lift it off its stand and it's
totally wearable and then over to this
side here is all of my swords and stuff
so I would have a lot more of these but
I really don't have room for them so
this one here is mastizaade
we've got a hail of energy sword I'll
say year's sword from assassin's creed
this one's really well made and very
sharp Finn's golden sword of battle here
which is obviously just plastic and kind
of crappy but that's where Adventure
Time so it's cool in case of electro
Ransa litrenta retro lance of chaos even
keel which is from dockside is this is
really heavy and I'm absolutely in love
with it it's really cool
oh my Yoshi slip is there and I have
escapable and this is my
when it's actually on so it looks really
bad because the windows actually open so
there's enough light for the video so I
have blackout blinds so you can see
perfectly that I've also got surround
sound so this is where all of my actual
gaming takes place even the 64 fits in
and brain mode is just the most
confusing thing out so thank you
everyone for watching I hope you enjoyed
my video